[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
mit heinz wolf und marietta slomka guten
abend zwei erkenntnisse des gestrigen
abends politik ist nicht langweilig und
parteimitglied schafften lohnen sich
wenn man einfluss nehmen will
knapp 115.000 spd mitglieder haben eine
entscheidung getroffen die auswirkungen
haben dürfte auf die geschicke der
ganzen republik
da mögen sich die restlichen 61
millionen wahlberechtigten mehrheitlich
eine fortsetzung der großen koalition
wünschen
darauf kommt es im moment aber nicht an
die neue spd spitze muss ihren anhängern
jetzt liefern
fragt sich ob es esken und walter
borjans gelingt innerhalb der groko zu
liefern oder nicht und da kommt dann der
koalitionspartner ins spiel
fragen dazu gleich an markus söder doch
erstmal thomas reichert mit dem bericht
aus berlin am tag danach
wer ihn rein kommen sahen gestern abend
der ahnte schon dass olaf scholz
verloren hatte dass sich da ein beben
ereignet das in partei und regierung
alles auf den kopf stellen könnte hier
die siegreichen außenseiter dort der
vizekanzler der großen koalition der um
fassung ringt der graben der sich da
auftut ist unübersehbar
die einen wollen weiter regieren jetzt
müssen wir mit einer klarkommen weil
eins eint uns alle wir wollen regieren
wir wollen gestalten ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass irgendjemand die
grundrente nicht will
wir wollen alle das klimapaket
mitgestalten und das kann man nur wenn
man regiert und darüber werden wir reden
müssen doch das lager um walter borjans
und essen weiß noch gar nicht ob es
regieren will
es hat forderungen an die union und
zeichnet rote linien für den
koalitionsbruch
wenn die union jetzt gar keine
zugeständnisse macht wenn es keine
verhandlungen gibt dann also sehe ich
nicht aus die große koalition weiter
geführt werden kann weil diese
zugeständnisse sind eine bedingung dafür
dass man weitermachen könnte in der spd
reden sie nun viel von einigkeit es gibt
sogar ein versöhnungs video das zeigt
wie tief der riss geht ob scholz ein
standhafter sozialdemokrat sei wird
esken vor ein paar tagen gefragt das
kann ich im lauf der sehr sehr langen
jahre die urlaubs schulz jetzt tätig ist
so nicht beurteilen ehrlich gesorgt
umgekehrt war so ziemlich das gesamte
partei establishment gegen die
unerfahrenen außenseiter stephan weil
etwa erklärte esken habe dinge gesagt
bei dem sich mir die nackenhaare
sträuben und jetzt jetzt kommt ein
parteitag der spd der alles kippen und
den bürgern erklären soll was groko
gegner wie kevin kühnert mit diesem
beben wollen die erwarten dass man mit
ihrem täglichen leben und den
rahmenbedingungen auch pfleglich umgeht
pfleglich heißt nicht eine regierung die
sichtbar an rückhalt verliert auf teufel
komm raus am leben zu halten aber es
heißt eben schon kühe vorzugehen und dh
wir warten jetzt unseren parteitag erst
mal
die union befindet sich der wein immer
noch in einer art schockstarre
alle wollten scholz den fortbestand der
groko und jetzt jetzt wird die
parteivorsitzende möglichst schnell
einfach weiterarbeiten
für die cdu ist ganz klar wir stehen zu
dieser koalition wir stehen zu dieser
koalition auf der grundlage die
verhandelt ist und wir wollen uns
schnell der sacharbeit widmen
zurück zur sache bei zum bestehenden
koalitionsvertrag aber wollen die
designierten neuen parteichefs gerade
nicht walter borjans und essen haben
neue forderungen beim mindestlohn
grundrente und klima an denen sich am
ende auch das überleben der groko
entscheiden wird und markus so dass uns
zugeschaltet csu chef und bayerischer
ministerpräsident guten abendessen guten
namen großkurth mit blick auf das neue
spd duo sagt ihr kollege von der cdu der
generalsekretär ports irak wir freuen
uns auch vertrauensvolle zusammenarbeit
zum wohle unseres landes freuen sie sich
auch schon
na ja zunächst einmal respektiere die
entscheidung das ist nicht der erste
wechsel bei der spd in dieser
legislaturperiode
insofern respekt vor der entscheidung
und ich würde mal er sein
man ist gespannt wie es weitergeht denn
die aussagen von gestern müssen hier in
dieser woche finalisiert werden an einem
parteitag was da muss mal gewählt werden
mal sehen mit welchem ergebnis die
beiden unterstützung finden und
natürlich wie der leitantrag und die
bewertung dann aussieht für die
zukünftige zusammenarbeit in der großen
koalition
wie es weitergeht das wird natürlich
auch ganz stark vom koalitionspartner
also auch von ihnen abhängen wäre denn
die union bereit sich dazu bewegen und
nachzuverhandeln koalitionsvertrag
verhandelt er sogar durch ein mitglieder
votum der spd entschieden worden plus
weil ein parteivorsitzender wechselt
verhandelt man kein koalitionsvertrag
neu damit bei der cdu erlebt dann bis
bei uns erlebt und bei der spd zum
zweiten mal
man kann nicht ständig neu verhandeln
weil neue leute kommen die leute treten
ein in eine entsprechende situation
wissen sie am ende kommt sie nicht
darauf an was nützt der spd sondern was
nützt deutschland wir sind eher dazu den
rand voranzubringen
natürlich wird man reden das ist
selbstverständlich in einem
koalitionsvertrag der koalition dass man
redet aber nicht einfach neu verhandeln
und schon gar nicht forderungen
diskutiert die rein ideologisch
motiviert sind und ihnen einen wahlkampf
abzufedern in den koalitionsvertrag
steht nun auch dass man mitte der
legislaturperiode neu bewerten und
prüfen kann ob aufgrund zur tat
aktueller entwicklungen neue vorhaben
vereinbart werden müssten
also insofern der vertrag als solcher
schließt es nicht aus dass man da zum
beispiel noch ein großes
investitionspaket mit aufnimmt oder
veränderungen beim mindestlohn
natürlich kann man darüber reden dass
man beispielsweise in der steuer-
endlich was voranbringt für die
wirtschaftliche lage bei vielen
tausenden die entlassen werden der
nächsten jahre der automobilindustrie
wäre es sinnvoll da etwas zu tun die
unternehmensteuerreform ist jetzt nicht
das hat frau könnte es sein dass sie da
recht haben aber es kommt drauf an was
auf dem zettel von den beiden steht
sondern auf dem zettel der deutschen
politik stehen muss und also natürlich
wird man immer wieder reden haben neue
session sie wir haben zum beispiel
gerade beim klimaschutz sehen wir gerade
zu einem offiziellen
verfassungsrechtlich verfahren nämlich
in einem vermittlungsausschuss zwischen
bundestag und bundesrat
da keine nicht rede ist einfach wieder
zurück das ist da ein bisschen zu spät
das müssen wir jetzt alles entscheiden
also wir sind natürlich offen zu reden
aber nicht den koalitionsvertrag neu zu
verhandeln und schon gar nicht
irgendwelche juso projekte die relativ
weit ab von der ökonomischen realität
sind und rein ideologisch geprägt sind
jetzt völlig neu die deutsche politik
einzuführen
naja sie zum beispiel wollen ja ein
hightech agenda bayern umsetzen und wenn
jetzt das neue spd du mehr investitionen
gerade im bereich der digitalisierung
fordert 500 milliarden in zehn jahren
wäre das nicht vielleicht auch was für
die csu ganz attraktiv sein konnte um
die große koalition zu retten
naja sie wissen jetzt auch einfach nur
irgendwelche mond summen zu fordern und
dabei gegen jede form der finanziellen
seriosität zu verstoßen
keiner das ziel sei es werden ja zwei
seiten zu überlegen wir müssen auf der
eins natürlich mehr investieren in
hightech technologie aber nicht
gleichzeitig in immense soziale projekte
müssen auf der einen seite schauen dass
wir finanzielle solidität haben damit
nicht auf der anderen seite in europa
alle anderen staaten die ohnehin schon
probleme haben mit ihren schulden
situationen dann auch diese situationen
sicht völlig aus den fugen gerät also
ich glaube man muss vernunft
ökonomische vernunft jahr und jetzt
keine wolkenkuckucksheime zu machen wie
gesagt wir werden reden das gehört zum
guten stil einer koalition dazu aber
keine absurden pläne angenommen dieses
diese gespräche fördern zunächst wären
neuwahlen nicht gerade für die union und
auch sehr gefährlich also für die spd
mit ihren 13 prozent auch nicht schön
aber die union hat jetzt auch nicht dem
kanzlerkandidaten oder die
kanzlerkandidatin hinter der sich die
ganzen parteien cdu und csu kraftvoll
versammeln zurzeit mal abgesehen davon
dass wir noch nie eine wahl gegeben
hatte der es nicht kandidaten gegeben
hat für diese wahl bei der spd ist
skeptisch ob überhaupt jemand aufstellen
soll
da streitet sich das neue du ja noch ein
bisschen da frage ob das sinnvoll ist
oder nicht
aber das ist doch nicht die frage jetzt
die frage ist jetzt wir haben eine
halbzeit
und welche mannschaft verlässt ihn nach
einer halbzeit das spielfeld im fußball
jetzt gilt es den auftrag der wähler an
welle anzunehmen umzusetzen müssen
deutschland gut regieren
da darf man natürlich unterschiedliche
positionen haben ist doch klar
aber man darf nicht von vornherein schon
zu antreten nach dem motto wenn diese
forderung nicht erfüllt wird dann
steigen wir aus der gruppe aus die spd
muss wirklich aufpassen es gibt
großartige persönlichkeit
wir haben die letzten monate mit freier
beispielsweise frau schwesig sehr gut
und auch mal so ist es so ist das aber
sieht die beiden neuen
parteivorsitzenden sind ja nicht allein
da es gibt die bundesregierung es gibt
den fraktionen
es gibt ein parteivorstand und alle
müssen jetzt ihre verantwortung
wahrnehmen ansonsten könnte passieren
dass die spd irgendwann den weg der
französischen sozialisten geht die
gefahr besteht daran hat keine interesse
auch wir nicht haben sie dann
sicherheitshalber schon mal mit grünen
und fdp telefoniert nein wahnsinnig dass
das vielleicht ganz sinnvoll wäre weil
das kann eventuell auch an ganz schnell
gehen
also eines ist doch klar die spd muss
jetzt zunächst mal in dieser woche für
sich klären es gibt ja glaube ich am
donnerstag in präsidium und
parteivorstand der dann den leitantrag
noch einmal vorbereitet
dort wird man schon näheres sehen dann
wird der parteitag selber sicherlich
eine richtung vorgeben müssen
in welche richtung es gehen soll und
zwar die eigentliche frage ist ja ist
man innerlich bereit zur
regierungsverantwortung ist man
innerlich in der der lage noch regieren
zu wollen sind die neuen
parteivorsitzenden dazu auch hier haben
die innere kraft dazu oder wollen sie
von vornherein entweder
irgendeine form von links bündnis nach
ganz links außen oder wollen sie am
liebsten gar nichts mehr mitregieren zu
tun haben was natürlich nichts anderes
ist als sich selbst aufgabe einer
demokratie den verantwortung zu
übernehmen
das ist der kern bestand sagt markus
söder ich danke für das gespräch
das interview haben wir vor zwei stunden
geführt mehr hintergründe zur neuen spd
spitze und den möglichen folgen für die
große koalition finden sie auf hatte die
zu den bitteren erkenntnissen der
letzten jahre gehört dass die
pressefreiheit nicht nur in staaten wie
china russland oder der türkei mit füßen
getreten wird
auch mitten in der europäischen union
kann es journalisten passieren dass sie
in ihrer eigenen wohnung regelrecht
hingerichtet werden
so geschehen in der slowakei oder mit
ihrem auto in die luft gesprengt werden
so geschehen auf malta in beiden fällen
ging es um recherchen über korruption im
oktober 2017 starb die journalistin
daphne caruana galizia bei einem
bombenanschlag auf ihr auto ihre
recherchen wurden von anderen kollegen
die sich weltweit zusammenschlossen
weitergeführt und im eu inselstaat malta
begann sich die bevölkerung zu erheben
gegen eine regierung die nicht nur wenig
interesse an aufklärung zeigte sondern
an diesem auftragsmord womöglich selbst
beteiligt war jetzt am abend kündigte
maltas premierminister seinen rücktritt
an
alissa jung berichtet sie ziehen heute
wieder vor das gericht in malta sie
demonstrieren mafia steht auf ihren
schildern
der vorwurf korruption und
vetternwirtschaft sie meinen die
regierung um premier muskat aber vor
allem sollen sie die auftraggeber des
anschlags an der journalistin daphne gar
anna galizia decken heute verkündet der
premier er wird zurücktreten aber erst
im januar für die familie von barrois
anna galizia kaum zu ertragen
solange er im amt ist sind die
ermittlungen behindert und das könnte
den fall beeinflussen
wir haben bereits zeichen von
politischer einflussnahme beobachtet
weil es so lange gedauert hat bis sich
überhaupt etwas getan hat
es wird keine gerechtigkeit ohne
veränderungen geben
die letzten tage haben gezeigt dass wir
recht hatten wir können keine
gerechtigkeit haben bevor es einen
politischen wechsel gibt
am 16 oktober 2017 starb die
journalistin eine bombe explodierte
unter dem sitz ihres autos ferngezündet
per handy die vermutung einzelne
personen waren durch galiciens
recherchen unter druck geraten und
wollten sie loswerden
kurz danach wurden drei polizeibekannte
männer festgenommen und des mordes
angeklagt die frage bleibt wer hat sie
beauftragt die menschen auf malta
fordern gerechtigkeit für das für sie
ist seit dem anschlag nicht nur die
pressefreiheit sondern auch der
rechtsstaat in gefahr
am samstag wurde der geschäftsmann
jürgen fennec wegen beihilfe zum mord an
garro anna galizia angeklagt zuvor hatte
er laut medienberichten den behörden
einen deal angeboten
straffreiheit gegen informationen
informationen die unter anderem muss
kabinettschefs cambridge die
tourismusminister mizzi und den
wirtschaftsminister cardona betreffen
muskat regierung lehnte den antrag ab
scam bree und mizzi traten von ihren
ämtern zurück da muss hat diese menschen
immer wieder geschützt und verteidigt
hat kommt nun auch kritik aus brüssel
deshalb wird das europaparlament am
montag eine beobachtergruppe nach malta
schicken
seit über zwei jahren fordern wir
gerechtigkeit und jetzt zum ersten mal
war ich zu hoffen dass wir sie wirklich
bekommen
aber solange premier muskat im amt und
der fall darf nicht aufgeklärt ist
wollen sie hier weiter demonstrieren
nach deutschland sachsen geht nach kenia
damit beginnt die nachrichten von 13
monate nach der landtagswahl haben sich
cdu grüne und spd auf einen
koalitionsvertrag geeinigt die drei
parteien stellten die vereinbarung für
eine gemeinsame regierungsarbeit bevor
die cdu und ministerpräsident
kretschmann wird über den vertrag nun
auf einem parteitag abstimmen spd und
grüne wollen ihre basis befragen der
neue co vorsitzende der hfg tino köhler
hat dem bundesamt für verfassungsschutz
vorgeworfen die afg als
oppositionspartei schwächen zu wollen
er sagte in einem interview mit der zdf
sendung berlin direkt wir wissen alle
dass der verfassungsschutz in
deutschland politisch agiert um die
größte oppositionspartei zu schädigen
und zu diffamieren
auf dem heute zu ende gegangenen
parteitag in braunschweig hat sich der
afw vorstand um das führungsduo aus jörg
merten und thilo copala neu formiert das
gemäßigtere lager in der afg spitze gilt
als geschwächt dessen komponente
vertreter georg pastowski teil
gottschalk und albrecht glaser sind
nicht mehr im vorstand vertreten
ursula von der leyen hat heute ihr amt
als neue eu kommissionspräsidenten
angetreten
in einer kurzen rede zur feier der
lissabon verträge sagte die cdu
politikerin
sie wolle europa stärken ihre
angekündigten schwerpunkte sind ein
dauerhaftes wachstum für europa ein
entschlossenes handeln gegen den
klimawandel und eine nachhaltige
regelung der migration
einen tag vor beginn des
weltklimagipfels hat un generalsekretär
kritisch mit einem eindringlichen appell
dazu aufgefordert mehr für den
klimaschutz zu tun
unser krieg gegen die natur muss
aufhören und wir wissen dass das möglich
ist sagte görisch in madrid dort nehmen
an der zweiwöchigen klimakonferenz
vertreter aus fast 200 staaten teile in
der elitetruppe der bundeswehr ksk gibt
es laut bild am sonntag einen
rechtsextremismus verdacht es werde
gegen einen unteroffizier ermittelt auch
zwei stabsoffiziere stünden unter
verdacht sie sollen auf einer privaten
feier den hitlergruß gezeigt haben
verteidigungsministerin kramp
karrenbauer kündigte ein hartes vorgehen
an man untersuche ob es ein netzwerk
gibt mit gottesdiensten haben die beiden
christlichen kirchen ihre
spendenaktionen zur weihnachtszeit
begonnen
die evangelische hilfsorganisation brot
für die welt eröffnete im
schleswig-holsteinischen rendsburg ihre
aktion unter dem motto hunger nach
gerechtigkeit in freiburg feierte das
katholische lateinamerika hilfswerk
adveniat seinen auftakt
das ruft unter dem motto friede mit dir
zu spenden auf
mit dem ersten advent heute beginnt für
die katholische kirche in deutschland
ein experiment mit noch unbekanntem
ausgang der sogenannte synodale weg ein
reformprozess der durchaus brisant ist
zwei jahre lang sollen würdenträger und
kirchenbasis also engagierte gläubige
miteinander diskutieren und dabei wird
nichts ausgespart
es soll um den umgang der kirche mit
macht gehen um sexualmoral und das
zölibat und um die position der frauen
in der kirche
zweimal im jahr wird dann eine große
synodale versammlung tagen unter
teilnahme der 69 deutschen im vatikan
wird dieser deutsche weg schon jetzt
skeptisch beäugt sibylle bassler
berichtet
ein sprayer im altarraum ein graffiti
mit modernen heiligen die etwa dem
rüssel blower etwa zonen oder der
rettungsboot kapitänin carola rakete
fast jedes mittel ist dem katholischen
pfarrer rainer maria schießler recht um
die menschen in die kirche zu bringen
den exodus bekämpfen wie der 59 jährige
münchner die kirchenaustritte bezeichnet
kirche muss wieder zur heimat für die
menschen werden
viele haben diese heimat verloren nicht
zuletzt durch die ganzen skandal
berichte mit missbrauchsskandal auf
kirchen
das ist unser anspruch muss wieder
spüren dass herr ortes wo die liebe es
sagen hat so lange weg aber kein
aussichtsloser
umso wichtiger sei es das vertrauen der
gläubigen wieder zu gewinnen denn die
enttäuschung an der basis ist groß so
konnten bleiben und so verlieren die
natürlich die ganzen leute und das ist
ja kein zustand weil die kirche sich
immer mehr entfernt von der realität
aber wie kann die katholische kirche
wieder an glaubwürdigkeit gewinnen
zur gleichen zeit wenige hundert meter
entfernt in der münchner frauenkirche
wird von kardinal reinhard marx und
vertretern der katholischen laien mit
einem gottesdienst der sogenannte
synodale peak eingeleitet ein
reformprozess bei dem in den kommenden
zwei jahren bischöfe und laien vertreter
darüber beraten werden wie ihre kirche
wieder aus der krise gelangen kann
da bedeutet finden wir eine neue
einmütigkeit etwa in den fragen wie wir
die priester die zukunft denken wie wir
auch die ganzen herausforderungen über
sexualität und beziehungen zu reden zu
sprechen
wie macht und teilhabe da ist ich hoffe
dass wir einen schritt weiter kommen wie
wir die rolle der frau in der kirche
noch stärken
die aufarbeitung der missbrauchsskandale
soll nach auffassung der laienvertreter
zentraler punkt dieses prozesses sein
wenn es nicht eine saubere aufarbeitung
mit personellen konsequenzen
strafrechtlichen ergebnissen des
sexuellen missbrauchs gibt dann brauchen
wir auch nicht für einen neuen synodalen
weg zu werden
der synodale weg er gilt vielen
als große chance mit geradezu
revolutionären ansätzen die weihe
verheirateter männer zu priestern in
entlegenen teilen der amazonasregion
hält etwa bischof franz-josef oberbeck
vom bistum essen für vorstellbar dies
wäre
zitat für unsere tradition ein großer
schritt in der st maximilian kirche
bereitet sich pfarrer schießler
unterdessen auf den adventsgottesdienst
vor
auch er hofft auf konkrete ergebnisse
des reformprozesses denn der zölibat und
die untergeordnete rolle der frauen in
der kirche entsprechen nicht dem wesen
einer christlichen gemeinde verheiratete
männer und frauen die die christliche
ehe leben leben die weniger radikal als
ich es ins leben wie soll ich eine
gesellschaft da draußen ständig sagen
dass jeder mensch die selbe würde
besitzt in meinem eigenen betrieb in
anführungszeichen ist dies aber nicht
der fall
neue wege gehen traut euch es ist diese
botschaft die auch heute am ersten
advent die menschen in scharen zu ihm in
die kirche kommen lässt traut euch das
könnte auch das motto für den synodalen
weg sein und jetzt nochmal heinz mit
anderen meldungen des tages
der stardirigent mariss jansons ist tot
er starb im alter von 76 jahren in sankt
petersburg als jansons leitete seit 2003
das symphonieorchester des bayerischen
rundfunks zählte zu den bedeutendsten
dirigenten weltweit zur fußball
bundesliga borussia mönchengladbach hat
heute 4 2 gegen den sc freiburg gewonnen
und bleibt damit an der tabellenspitze
im zweiten sonntagsspiel hat wolfsburg
gegen bremen verloren mit 2 3
das formel-1-saisonfinale in abu dhabi
hat weltmeister lewis hamilton gewonnen
er feierte einen ungefährdeten
start-ziel-sieg vor max verdoppeln und
schaden erklärt mit diesem elften sieg
in diesem jahr bricht hamilton außerdem
den punkterekord in der königsklasse des
motorsports
sebastian vettel landet nach einer panne
beim boxenstopp nur auf platz fünf
hamilton steht bereits seit anfang
november als weltmeister fest morgen
beginnt in madrid die weltklimakonferenz
eines der großen themen wird sein wie
sich die menschheit im zuge von
klimawandel und erderwärmung ihre
lebensräume erhält ein beispiel wüsten
und halbwüsten bedecken heute schon mehr
als ein drittel der landfläche auf
unserem globus und sie wachsen
experten schätzen bis 2050 würde dadurch
jeder fünfte mensch seine
lebensgrundlage verlieren
am stärksten betroffen ist die sahel
zone südlich der sahara in dieser
entwicklung etwas entgegenzusetzen wurde
hier schon vor zwölf jahren eine große
initiative gestartet die sogenannte
great green 0 7750 kilometer lang von
äthiopien im osten bis zum senegal an
der westküste afrikas bei dieser vision
einer großen grünen mauer geht es vor
allem darum mit wiederaufforstung der
entwaldung in der region
nun entgegen zu wirken und die örtliche
landwirtschaft den klimawandel besser
anzupassen
unser korrespondent tim kröger waren
äthiopien unterwegs und hat dort
immerhin einen grünen hoffnungsschimmer
gesehen
endlich kann titel maria das heim in
wochen lang durfte keiner der bauern aus
der gegend auf diesem grundstück sein
vieh weiden das gras konto hoch wachsen
jetzt können sie häufiger futter in den
kommenden regenarmen monaten ernten wir
sind froh dass es wieder grüner wird mit
dem gras füttern wir unsere tiere und
bauen unsere dächer frühjahr war es
carla hier jetzt ist es angenehmer neben
dem futter für die tiere wurden auch
bäume gepflanzt um die zunehmende
entwaldung in der region rückgängig zu
machen ein kleiner streifen ist bereits
entstanden der für ein besseres
mikroklima sorgen sollen
terrassen sollen die erosion der böden
stoppen auch die neuen bienenstöcke
sollen helfen
als wir anfingen haben sich die bauern
gewährt und gesagt dass das ihr
weideland ist aber wir haben mit ihnen
gesprochen und experten haben ihnen das
prinzip erklärt das projekt im norden
äthiopiens ist teil der so genannten
großen grünen mauer ein film der
vereinten nationen zeigt wie gigantisch
das projekt ist anfangs ging es um die
ausweitung der sahara die durch einen
ball von bäumen entlang der sahel-zone
gestoppt werden sollte mittlerweile aber
geht es um mehr
die sahel zone gilt als die region die
weltweit mit am stärksten vom
klimawandel betroffen ist das land ist
durch über bewirtschaftung zerstört
worden die große grüne wand soll es
wieder nutzbar machen sagt der
zuständige koordinator der afrikanischen
union mit abbott haut es geht darum das
land zu managen so dass die menschen
sich dem klimawandel an
essen können es geht darum dass das land
wieder treibhausgase speichern kann
es geht darum jobs und wohlstand zu
schaffen und so für mehr frieden in der
region zu sorgen
vor allem der zunehmende terrorismus und
ethnische konflikte in der region würden
den erfolg der großen grünen land
bedrohen sie ist ein mosaik aus
hunderten verschiedenen projekten wie
dem in äthiopien
viele sind erfolgreich viele aber auch
nicht effektiv sagen experten
wir müssen das konzept der investitionen
in die große grüne wand ändern
möglicherweise gibt es viele
erfolgsgeschichten aus den saarländern
die wir einfach nur vervielfältigen
müssen und die basieren auf den
erkenntnissen und der inspiration der
bauern in ihren dörfern die sehen was
funktioniert die ziele der großen grünen
mauer sind ehrgeizig 100 millionen
hektar land sollen wieder aufgeforstet
werden zehn millionen jobs sollen
entstehen der weg dahin aber ist noch
weit
die weltklimakonferenz wird eines der
themen seien über die nächste woche
berichtet wird benjamin dialog ski hat
noch drei weitere ereignisse ausgewählt
für unseren sonntäglichen wochenausblick
[Musik]
die nato feiert ab dienstag in london
ihren siebzigsten geburtstag mit einem
großen gipfel
ausgerechnet jetzt ist das bündnis
zerstritten denn frankreichs präsident
makro hatte die nato neulich als hirntot
bezeichnet auch sonst herrscht nicht
gerade einigkeit unter den
bündnispartnern zb in der türkei frage
na dann frohes fest
am freitag besucht bundeskanzlerin
merkel das ehemalige vernichtungslager
auschwitz nach helmut schmidt 1977 und
helmut kohl 89 und 95 wird merkel die
dritte deutsche regierungschefin dort
seien bisher hatte die kanzlerin die
lager in buchenwald und dachau besucht
zur erhalt der gedenkstätte in auschwitz
bringt merkel 60 millionen euro mit
[Applaus]
ebenfalls am freitag wird die spd wohl
endlich wieder eine parteispitze haben
denn nach dem sieg im
mitgliederentscheid werden saskia esken
und norbert walter borjans am nächsten
wochenende vom parteitag wohl bestätigt
werden
die monatelange übergangszeit ist dann
vorbei und die spd so hofft sie endlich
mit einer kräftigen doppelspitzen stimme
sprechen
oder singen
und beim wetter ist der ausblick zum
start in die neue woche so
morgen gibt es im norden örtlich
regenschauer in den östlichen
mittelgebirgen und an den alpen fällt
etwas schnee sonst ist es trüb oder
aufgelockert bewölkt die temperaturen
erreichen 0 bis 8 grad
am dienstag fällt im nordosten etwas
regen sonst ist es in der neuen woche
meist trocken im süden zeigt sich
abseits einiger nebelfelder auf die
sonne an den temperaturen ändert sich
aber wenig passend zur jahreszeit spielt
die neue zdf sonntags krimi serie im
schnee der pass hochkarätig besetzt mit
einem deutsch-österreichischen
ermittlerpaar und die nächste heute
express gibt es dann um 0 uhr 30 und
hier erwarten sie morgen christian
sievers und gundula gause
schönen abend noch
[Musik]